[Musique]
tu es lundi québec met en place
l'obligation de présenter le passeport
vaccinale dans les commerces de 1500
mètres carrés et plus certains jugent
que c'est trop demander d'autres qu'on
ne va pas assez loin note aux seat
vendredi avec richard darveau président
de l'association québécoise de la
quincaillerie et des matériaux de
construction et chars milliards qui est
le président directeur général de la
fédération des chambres de commerce du
québec messieurs bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur françois richard darveau
votre association qui vous l'avez
exprimé cette semaine s'oppose au
passeport vaccinale dans les
quincailleries et vous avez exposé
encore votre situation au gouvernement
aujourd'hui est ce que le gouvernement
vous entendant votre appel ah oui il
nous entend s que le décret dont on n'a
pas vu encore le texte final semble-t-il
ça va arriver ce soir va tenir compte de
nos demandes où on va s'ajuster au fil
des premiers jours de son application ça
reste à voir mais notre point principal
monsieur fillion c'est simple c'est que
depuis le début de la pandémie on a
considéré au gouvernement que aller à
l'épicerie aller à la pharmacie et puis
aller à la quincaillerie ces trois
gestes essentiels il faut qu' aucun
citoyen en soit privé et puis tout à
coup à partir de lundi prochain ben si
vous avez un problème à chez vous je
vous n'êtes pas ou vaccin ou totalement
vaccinés ou pour envoyer quelqu'un
d'autre ouais
ça veut juste dire qu'il y aura une
petite barrière de plus on était surpris
on ne s'attendait pas ce d'autant que ça
fonctionne quand même assez bien dans
les centres de rénovation et beaucoup
d'humanité qui s'est développée au fil
des derniers mois entre les clients et
les employés ça se passe ça se passe
bien on a pas on n'a pas entendu de
foyers d'éclosion non plus
donc tout le monde tout le monde dit ça
qui est pas d'éclosion chez soi georges
entendu ça depuis le début de la
pandémie dans les restaurants dans les
bars tout le monde nous a dit qu'ils
avaient pas d'éclosion c'était toujours
ailleurs chars milliards vous êtes
favorable vos passeports vaccinale mais
vous étiez soulagé que ça touche pas les
petites entreprises est ce que votre
position a évolué parce que des propos
comme ceux de monsieur d'arv on a quand
même entendu beaucoup
non mais écoutez je vous dirais que
c'est certain qu'à la fédération au
couvre un nombre d'entreprises qui plus
large et on n'est plus à l'époque de
classer nos malheurs en ce moment donc
nous ce qui est important c'est que pour
les petits commerçants qui ont un ou
deux employés c'était vraiment une lubie
de penser on pourrait gérer le passeport
ordinaire comme comme comme pour
commander vos le faire en fait dans les
grandes surfaces alors je suis très
sensible aux commentaires de monsieur
d'amour j'espère qu'il y avait des
modulations entre pour des passes à
certains teams hommes qui font du big to
be donc du snes
monsieur médias c'est important quand
même parce que je pense que les les gens
qui font de la construction et qui vont
ensuite dans les quincailleries parce
qu'il ya nous comme comme citoyen là qui
voulant aller chercher une coupe de
planches mais il ya les gens de la
construction qui doivent y aller c'est
ça monsieur darveau kivu et dans le fond
on pense que ce point là et gagner on
s'attend sur wii on considère que le
passeport sera applicable à ce qu'on
appelle le grand public mais les
entreprises comme l'a dit mon collègue
ce ne seront pas soumis à cette ça vous
le savez nos produits de votre rencontre
j'ai dit on pense on sens pense que ça
s'en va vers ça on va le savoir tard ce
soir ou demain mais permettez monsieur
fillion d'insister sur un point que tous
les non vaccinés au partiellement
vacciner vont continuer d'aller dans la
quincaillerie mais vont se ruer vers les
plus petites donc est-ce qu'on va pas de
déplacer le problème de risque de
contagion du canton vaud dans un home
depot un réno dépôt il ya de l'espace
des allées sont larges les plafonds son
rôle quand on se retrouve dans un
magasin de quartier est plus étroit et
la 100% de ces gens là vont pas
commencer à ne pas réparer leurs maisons
on parle de 800 milles où un million de
personnes qui vont se retrouver dans les
plus petites surfaces ça nous apparaît
le plus gros problème je comprends mais
on cherche des solutions en ce moment
pour faire fonctionner notre société
normalement et vivre avec la coved 19s
que les entreprises n'ont pas un rôle
majeur à jouer avec le passeport
vaccinale justement pour être capable de
faire fonctionner la société puis
confirme pas l'économie une partie de
l'économie comme on le fait je pose la
question de chars milliards d'abord m'a
écouté
c'est un coup un peu une lettre ouverte
qu'on a fait cette semaine qui est parue
dans la presse le midi je pense que
l'équation qui la plus réaliste possible
en ce moment c'est une couverture
vaccinale optimale une augmentation
importante avec citation mondiale aussi
en passant pour des mesures de
restriction collective qui sont suivis
même si ça ne me tente pas mais aussi
des initiatives privées qui peuvent
venir donc d'entrepreneurs qui prennent
la décision d'exiger la vaccination elle
a quand même qu'on a en ce moment c'est
que les entrepreneurs à courry plein on
a ingéré un risque sanitaire commercial
financier on n'a pas besoin de gérer un
risque judiciaire a dansé pour ça qu'on
demande au gouvernement d'agir de
définir un cadre qui va sécuriser les
employeurs qui doivent malheureusement
cette décision-là d'exiger la
vaccination ne pas avoir une épée de
damoclès qui la house une vrai potentiel
poursuite et d'attendre une décision du
tribunal administratif
richard de vous oui bah c'est pas demain
qu'on aura une loi il n'y avait pas
d'activité parlementaires dont je pense
que la solution est intéressante à moyen
terme puisque sans doute qu'ils avaient
d'autres pandémies il y en a pas eu
depuis quoi 30 ans depuis le sida alors
je pense qu'une loi est bien venu
maintenant ce que je recommanderais à
nos 1000 entreprises membres une fois qu
une loi qui existe d'aller dans ce sens
de toucher à l'intégrité physique de
leurs employés puisque c'est de ça dont
on parle la vaccination c'est une zone
très sensible au cours de dernières
années les citoyens ont gagné des droits
alors il faudra circonscrire cela est
aussi convenir c'est quoi une pandémie
pour qu'il porte des buts d'application
parce que l'or quand on danse de
passeports vaccinale on parle de
passeports vaccinale pour les clients
mais ce que vous dites monsieur
milliards c'est ça prend une loi pour
protéger les employeurs qui voudraient
imposer la vaccination obligatoire à
leurs travailleurs il ya des poursuites
partout au canada en ce moment parce que
c'est permis maintenant en fait il ya
une obligation du côté des entreprises
qui sont sous réglementation fédérale
alors vous vous pensez qu'on doit aller
plus loin dans le fond avec avec la
vaccination obligatoire ou alcool
passeport vaccinale disponible pour les
clients pour les uns pour les employés
pour les employeurs mais la conjugaison
du jus du verbe est important qu'ils
voudraient on ne demande pas à toutes
les entreprises de le faire et a au
passage je ne fais pas la prendre sur la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
québécois je pense est un vieux qui
complètement irréaliste je pense que
c'est la somme de rédaction qui va faire
la différence
ce qu'on dit par contre nous et monsieur
fignon monsieur d'envoi et moi on n'est
pas des élus on n'a pas la science
infuse ont mené des porte parole milieux
d'affaires et les gens d'affaires le
dise on voudrait bien suivre la
recommandation tacite du gouvernement
mais on a peur des poursuites
judiciaires et il ya des entreprises au
québec un des grands services juridiques
au gérer ça mais on n'a pas qu'ils n'ont
pas et qu'ils n'ont pas à gérer ça en
plus de devoir gérer parce patineurs la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre et j'en passe
j'apporterai un bémol si vous me
permettez on est en pénurie de main
d'oeuvre tout vous invitez vous en parle
à chaque émission ils sont aussi hors de
son continent les employés ont le gros
bout du bâton si certaines entreprises
une fois qu'il existe une loi qui leur
permet d'imposer la vaccination parmi
leurs effectifs ces travailleurs vont
aller travailler ailleurs là où on leur
imposera pas cela on n'est pas dans une
position quand même de force
actuellement tant qu'employeur mais
monsieur des personnes qui ont une
position force de toute façon c'est une
situation impossible on avait tous à vue
méfiez vous des gens qui pensent qu'ils
connaissent
y'en a pas
nous on pense que nous sommes de petites
actions si tout le monde est sympa si
tout le monde fait ça par monsieur
darveau c'est ça c'est ça l'enjeu aussi
si on a le passeport vaccinale pour
tenter de faire fonctionner pas pour
stigmatiser une partie de la population
mais pour tenter de faire fonctionner la
société l'économie ok faisons vivre on
claque aux vitres est ce que vous n'avez
pas une responsabilité de faire
fusionner cette solution là oui je vous
ferai remarquer d'abord que le passeport
vaccinale était imposée aux restaurants
aux établissements culturels sa part
empêcher de les fermer même si on
expliqué les plus sévères mesures
d'hygiène et de
distanciation pardon mais il me semble
que admettons qu'on est un groupe de 10
1 et qui en a neuf sur dix qui
fonctionne bien on va les appeler les
vaccinés
9,2 et puis là on est un groupe on
voyage ensemble y en a un qui est
toujours un retard qui suit pas la
marche à l'organisateur de choix il dit
bon excusez on va pénaliser les neuf
parce qu'il y en a un qui n'est pas à la
hauteur des autres l'on veut l'attendre
ou bien il va dire non aux
fonctionnaires qui est une oeuvre qui
veulent avancer avec moi donc on a des
travailleurs des employeurs qui veulent
avancer qui veulent travailler et le
travail ça fait partie de la santé
mentale pour que la santé financière
c'est sans doute ce qui est le plus
important pour éviter de chuter alors
ces gens veulent travailler ensemble ça
fonctionne super bien à partir du 24 de
partir du juridique on va jouer à la
police et on pense que ce climat là
voire un peu se détériorer malo alors on
va vérifier le décret effectivement qui
va sortir ce soir c'est intéressant de
vous en avoir parlé je comprends qu il y
aura d un assouplissement du décret pour
les contracteurs en construction si j'ai
bien compris on va vérifier ça monsieur
darveau monsieur milliards merci d'avoir
été avec nous merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit